david blevins is at stornum storm and so
uh so jeffrey
stood last time round is he likely to
face a contest
i think that is unlikely at this stage
nominations close at noon tomorrow sir
jeffrey
who as you say is the party's leader at
westminster is right now
the only candidate for this job and
let's face it who really would want to
be
leader of the dup given the situation
the party finds itself
in he is known to be more of a pragmatic
leader perhaps he's been 24 years an mp
he was the man who helped broker that
famous confidence and supply deal
with the tories bringing one billion
pounds in
back in 2017 when theresa may didn't
secure
a majority in the general election so he
would be the party's
third leader in the space of two months
but he's facing exactly the same old
problems arlene foster
was effectively deposed for not taking a
tough enough line
against the brexit protocol that trade
border in the irish sea
then edwin putz was effectively deposed
for not taking a tough enough line
against that trade border in the rsc
it's going to be very difficult for sir
jeffrey if indeed
he emerges as leader elect tomorrow to
commit to nominating a first minister to
ensure power sharing continues
unless he gets some sort of concession
on the protocol
from the prime minister as i say edwin
putz
the man who succeeded arlene foster for
an astonishing
21 days just has been talking for the
first time today
about his decision to resign after he
nominated a first minister
against the wishes of his own party this
is what he had to say to me
why did you proceed to nominate a first
minister
against the express wishes of your own
party
my focus um was in the northern ireland
protocol first and foremost
because constitutionally that is what is
damaging
northern ireland and our best asset
at this moment in time in fighting the
protocol is
actually having the assembly because our
ministers are
in the government offices rooms every
day of the week
proclaiming the issues around the
protocol the problems the protocol
and i believe that's having effect do
you regret nominating paul given as
first minister now
um i regret the fallout from it i think
that it was
the the right thing to do and it's the
right thing to do to ensure that we have
maximum leverage and
ultimately it was my intention
had we not got a success on the protocol
and then i would have been prepared to
pull paul given out of that job that was
something that i
wish to express but i didn't get the
opportunity to express
at what point did you realize edwin
pitt's leadership of the dup
was over was it when you came back out
of the assembly chamber after nominating
was it during the party officers meeting
at headquarters
well to be honest i i was busy all day
so i wasn't paying a lot of attention to
the media so
i didn't hear what was being said or or
what was going on but i knew at the
party officers meeting
that that um you know they were in a
particular place
and ultimately the majority of them
hadn't wished me to be leader in the
first instance
given how divided the party now is do
you regret the ousting
of arlene foster as leader of the dup
well i'm glad you asked that because we
need some clarity about that
because i i i filled um the position
that arlene held
and people perhaps think that i had much
greater role in that than what i
actually had and there was
there was lots going on in the ep and
and and there was
a significant issue there and you know
85 percent of the assembly group
had a particular view and that's that's
reflected
and i don't wish to make things um any
any more difficult for
for arlen she's now moved on you said a
moment ago people
overestimated perhaps your role in the
ice thing of arlene foster
who do you blame for the events
of recent days the meltdown in your
party i i think it was more
a collective of opinions than
individuals
and i think those opinions were very
widespread
so i i don't i think it'll be wrong to
apportion
to any individual um
the hosting of arlen foster
this obviously is difficult for you
personally has it had an impact on your
family as well
well obviously they're they're they're
they're hurt because they see a hurt
inflicted upon me
so you know i would suggest to any
politician to look after your family
first and foremost
because when everybody else moves on
your family's still there